We have a voicemail number.
That number is two one nine two David p.
Now this is a voicemail about 2020 most election
cycles.
This would be a perfectly reasonable question
to answer in the direct way that the person
wants me to answer it in 2020 we interpret
this question differently.
Take a listen to this and you'll know what
I mean.
Yeah.
My question is, uh, what do you think is going
to be the big deciding issues for swing states
like Iowa and the 2020 elections and what
candidate best champion those issues be them
Democrat or Republican.
So in a normal election year, I would say,
oh, it's going to be a healthcare and national
security and that's going to be, that is not
the analysis in 2020 in 2020 we have a situation
where this is going to ultimately be an election
that comes down to turnout and that is going
to be uh, effectively decided by what is the
perceived state of the American economy in
2020 health care plans.
We know at this point, Trump promised since
2015 a big beautiful health care plan.
It's not happening.
It didn't happen.
And even if Trump got something passed, it
would be terrible.
We know that most Democrats are now on board
with some version of Medicare for all.
Joe Biden wants to work around the edges and
make some improvements to Obamacare.
Okay, fine.
We understand what it is.
It is not ultimately going to be the difference
maker.
It is going to be what is turnout from both
people who voted for Trump in 2016 people
who did not vote for Trump in 2016 and people
who didn't vote at all in 2016 are we going
to be able to turn out our base or are we
not going to be able to do that?
And a lot of it will just be what is the perceived
strength of the American economy?
Tariffs will be a part of it.
The stock market will be a part of it.
Employment rates will be a part of it.
And uh, it is, that is the issue, so to speak.
But ultimately it is a referendum on Donald
Trump.
Even more, you know, I think back to in elections
I've covered, uh, or actually this was before
the show even started, but even in elections,
I paid attention to closely when George W.
Bush was up for reelection in 2004, it was
effectively a referendum on George W. Bush,
including on the disastrous economy at the
time.
And on the Iraq war.
It is difficult to remove an incumbent president.
The incumbency, the presidency has a significant
power of incumbency and ultimately a George
W. Bush was reelected, if I recall correctly,
because if something like a hundred or 150,000
votes in Ohio that went his way instead of
John Kerry's way.
Uh, I think that 2020 is even more of a referendum
on the president.
Then 2004 was on George W. Bush and ultimately
I appreciate the question.
I could rattle off.
Listen, you know, healthcare is more important
than gun safety.
People tend to vote more on a jobs plans than
they do on foreign policy.
We could do all of that stuff, but ultimately
that is not the way that this election is
going to go down.
And this is why it is so important, so important
that we turn the base out.
It's got to happen.
That is what this is going to ultimately hinge
on.
I would hope that in you mentioned Iowa in
Iowa, farmers are getting crushed and in Iowa
you may actually see the election hinge on
do farmers, people who know farmers, which
is a lot of Iowans recognize that Donald Trump's
trade war and tariffs have been what has so
significantly damaged the economy in Iowa
and hurt so many farmers.
I don't know the answer to that.
A lot of them say they're angry with Trump,
but they don't seem to be saying, I'm not
voting for Trump, which are two very different
things.
Recognizing that Trump did a bad is not the
same as saying I as a lifelong Republican
farmer am going to vote for a democrat.
That is much harder to get people to do.
We've got a great bonus show for you today.
Beto or work is blasting Breitbart after ejecting
their reporter.
This is going to be an interesting one.
I will also talk about a Japanese public transport
idea of invisible ink stank ink stamps to
identify Grover's on public transit.
And also we will talk about Montana men who
lied about military service, uh, who had been
ordered to where I am, a liar, signs in public.
Is this logical?
Is this an adult punishment or is this, uh,
something that is a, just a bit too childish
and that we should not be pursuing as part
of our legal systems actions?
All of those stories and more on today's bonus
show, become a member@joinpacmandotcomtogetinstantaccessorbecomeapatronatpatrion.com
slash David [inaudible], the David Pakman
show@davidpakman.com.